القلق المتعلقه
بتجدد الاشتباك خلال هذه الهدنه او اختراق
طرف اي طرف من الاطراف هذه الهدنه الى اي
مدى استفاد ان صح التعبير المواطنون
القطاعات المختلفه في الخرطوم ان كان
القطاع الصحي القطاع المصري في تجاره
تجاره التجزئه استفادوا من هذه الهدنه
بشكل او باخر
ازدهار الحياه معطله تماما يعني حتى الان
من خاصه هذه القطاعات القطاع المصرفي
والقطاع التجاري وحتى القطاع الصحي
الانبات تتحدث عن ان يعني معظم المستشفيات
الان هي خرجت عن الخدمه جراء هذه
الاشتباكات وانه حتى الان يعني القليل جدا
منها مازال يعمل ولكن بامكانات محدوده جدا
ويواجه مصائب عديده ويمكن ان كاميرا
الجزيره يعني رصدت هذا في اكثر من موقع
ولكن القطاع التجاري والقطاع المصارف وحتى
القطاع الحكومي يعني متوقف نتيجه لهذه
الصراعات حتى يعني عطله العيد التي دخلت
من دون ان يكون هناك اعلان عنها او حتى
اعلان عن نهايتها وبدايه دوام العمل
الحياه مشلوله تماما في الخرطوم الكره
الان هنا يحاول الهرب من الخرطوم الى
الخارج نتيجه لهذه الاشتباكات المستمره
وبالتالي لم يستفيد احد حتى الان من هذه
اله وهي وهو كانوا مامول من هذه الهدنه عن
ان تعيد بعض الامل في استدباب الحياه
وعودتها ولو تدريجيا في الخرطوم ولكن فيما
يبدو ان هذا الامر حتى الان مؤجل يعني
تلتزم هذه الاطراف هذه الهدنه في ظل يعني
حاله الاتهامات المتبادله التي تسيطر على
يعني الساحه تغذي من شراره هذا الصراع
وبالتالي المخاوف ما تزال يعني تتزايد من
قبل المواطنين الذين يعني يرقبون في سواء
كان الخروج بقلبي حاجتهم الاساسيه
والمساعده في تحسين الوضع الانساني او
فيمن يحاولون الفرار بعيدا عن هذه
المواجهات وايضا ارتفاع التكلفه الحياه
التي لا بدات تنزل بكارثه جديده اضافه الى
الكوارث الموجوده اصلا